à la maison de santé de nos droits on
vient de plus en plus loin pour se faire
soigner
j'habite pas à côté j'habite à quinzaine
de kilomètres mais bon j'aime bien venir
là bas parce que on a des rendez vous
comme on veut une facilité qui pourrait
bientôt changer
dites moi tout il vous est arrivé un
souci il est vrai qu'il ya cinq ans on
arrive à donner un rendez-vous dans la
journée quand les gens appeler à 8
heures à 14 heures grand maximum et
d'avoir rendez vous c'est difficile
aujourd'hui pour deux patientes l2 qui
est là depuis longtemps d'entendre que
l'on peut pas leur donner deux
rendez-vous dans la journée alors
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous
avec 2500 patients les deux généralistes
installés arriveront bientôt à
saturation
si pour l'heure il ne refuse personne il
redoute pourtant cette fatalité en se
mettant en scène dans cette vidéo
l'équipe espérait attirer un troisième
généralistes
je me suis précipité à l'intérieur et je
dis non a répondu elle s'est alors à 1
et marie-claude ces femmes sont dotés de
super pouvoirs
elle gère cet agenda d'une main de
maître son la comptable le courrier
n'est pas de médecin de garde sont
froids dans les situations les plus
critiques
et pourtant présent toujours le sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles lui un an et 70 mille
visionnages plus tard aucun candidat ne
s'est présenté
et tellement classe partout tellement
d'endroits où c'est peut être simple de
s'installer que finalement c'est pas
le médecin va faire il a besoin d'être
bien la wii va s'installer mais ça va
être le conjoint ou la conjointe rossi
qui va faire qu'il va s'installer dans
tel ou tel endroit parce qu'il va
trouver de la place
oui soit certes la réunion de crise
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour mais le
besoin se fait de plus en plus sentir
l'un des deux médecins arrivent en fin
de carrière on a quand même une échéance
on va dire d'ici à deux trois ans pour
trouver quelqu'un hormis le fait que ça
va saturer complètement
les conduire les consultations ça c'est
clair
ça va ça risque de mettre en péril aussi
la maison de santé si les soignants
reste confiant convaincus qu'ils
parviendront à recruter à nozeroy il y a
urgence